c'est un bon concept parce que il parle
d'un jeu qui blue quand on joue le
monopoly ces sénégalais en fait par un
jeu qui est normalement le trio font
découvrir comment est-ce que moi la
vraie vie il ya eu beaucoup de
l'injustice dans le jeu dans le sens où
les exemples cités obèses et que tu
avais savait tirer avec les devils
battus soit avancé de six mois comptant
lever 2 et enfin il y avait beaucoup de
titres les personnes qui jouent à notre
jeu se rendent compte vraiment des
inégalités produites en belgique il y en
a vraiment beaucoup et on s'en rend pas
compte comme sa vie notre vie mais on se
rend pas compte du nombre d'inégalités
l'année dernière on a regardé une vidéo
en cours de sciences sociales et c'était
vidéo qui représentait des jeunes
enfants qui jouaient un monopoly mais
c'était pas emmené au pub classique
il y avait des inégalités et qu'ils
étaient confrontés à des problèmes de la
société et on se renseigner pour voir si
le distingue réellement il est pisté par
et donc avec les professeurs on s'est
dit qu'on allait
nous avons demandé à des enfants de
jouer à un célèbre jeu de société
normalement les règles sont les mêmes
pour tous mais pas cette fois ci
bonjour les offres n des joueurs
favoriser pour 1 3 rue de maison telle
idée but de la partie un joueur possède
une carte qui lui permet de ne jamais
aller en prison
landry passer par la case départ
normalement excellent sens du droit
quand une fille c'est fort
et les garçons gagnent bon passons un
élève qui a senti beaucoup à ces
réactions étaient vraiment trop
longtemps et puis avec des élèves qui se
pose vraiment des questions jours
pourquoi c'est comme ça qu'est ce qui se
passe qu'est ce qui fait que je saigne
et mes qualités
pourquoi pourquoi j'écris pour une
énorme écart des mois la hausse est nul
qu il ya plein de pouvoir faire et tout
bas quand les horaires handicapés eh ben
[Musique]
mais comme ce n'était pas parce que ça
en gros c'est tout en moins de
du coup c'est n'importe quoi belle était
j'étais homosexuel dangereux et j'ai pas
pu parler pas me parler banzio
parce que ma les cards est parfois je
parlais aisément tétouan ça nous apprend
que par les femmes est un prince afin
d'aider les femmes gagnent moins que les
hommes
c'est une on va dire une batterie de
monopoly donc c'est vraiment mauvais
plis et donc de re se dit pourquoi pas
là ceci n'est pas un prix sachant que
rien n'y fait
[Musique]
thiam en belgique et on a par rapport à
ça crée des règles qu'on a ensuite
justifié par rapport justement la
réalité à des articles pour la trouver
et on les a appliqués dans le jeu donc
là l'idée d'un jeu comme celui là c'est
vraiment laid ce sont les élèves qui le
fasse pourquoi parce que c'est eux qui
vont parler à d'autres élèves des
chevaux mieux que si c'est le propre
avec son langage de profs qui va parler
aux élèves par ce jeu les élèves parlent
aux élèves présents d'autres écoles ça
n'a pas plus grand donc aller dans les
écoles mais des gens font des classes
béton de 5e parce que c'est ni casse à
l'âge où je cherche sur les enjeux
[Musique]
bon
où
m
[Musique]
parent
où